throughout history a cynical view of
human nature has often been used by
those in power to legitimize their power
right because if we cannot trust each
other that we need managers and CEOs and
kings and monarchs and generals right
then we need to be kept in control but
if we can actually trust each other if
most people are pretty decent that means
that we maybe don't need them and that
we can move to a very different kind of
society that is much more egalitarian
genuinely democratic with very different
kind of organizations different kind of
schools different kind of prisons
democracies etc etc so it has quiet yeah
big implications if you really think it
through
you've been breaking the internet a lot
over the last year so last year at the
Davos conference when he called out a
bunch of billionaires broke the internet
then you riled up took a Carlson and
broke the internet again and then you've
done it recently with this real-life
Lord of the Flies story that you've
unearthed yeah and it surprises me every
time that it happens yeah I mean I'm not
doing it on purpose
yeah it's a very weird experience to go
viral in a skill like that right you
sort of have your phone and your your
Twitter mentions and the you pay a visit
to the toilet and you come back and it's
like 3,000 new all right that's so cool
man so why don't you tell us about
before we even get into your new book
human humankind which is great why don't
you tell us this real life floated the
fly story that might be quite cool wait
stop sure so my new book is really about
a sort of silent revolution that has
taken place in science right so there
are a lot of scientists now from very
diverse disciplines and anthropology and
sociology and psychology you name it who
used to have a more cynical view of
human beings of who we are as a species
and are now actually more hopeful you
know they're not saying that people are
angel saying or anything we're clearly
not but they argue that our true
superpower as a species is actually our
ability to cooperate and to be friendly
to one another and to work together so
when I started writing this book I
realized that I had to take it up
against you know so many giants in
science in Western culture in our
literature you name it I mean Western
culture is to just permeate it with the
idea that people are selfish you know as
it goes back all the way to the ancient
Greeks the notion that our civilization
is only a thin veneer and that you know
especially during a time of crisis
during epidemic for example people we
call very nasty and they start stealing
and hoarding and blundering and you name
it so this idea goes back all the way to
the Asian Greeks you find it with the
Christian Church Fathers you know
Orthodox Christianity and the idea of
that
were born as sinners you also find it
with the enlightenment philosophers you
would expect some break there you know
between Orthodox Christianity in the
Latin philosophers but if you actually
look at the view of human nature it's
pretty similar
you know David Hume and it's almost hops
you know the famous British philosopher
or having quite a cynical view of human
nature and then again if you look at our
current capitalist system right the
central dogma seems to be people are
just selfish and deal with it that's
just the way things are and now one of
the sort of the most famous
manifestations of this idea in the 20th
century was this novel Lord of the Flies
that you know especially people in the
anglo-saxon world in the US and the UK
you know so many people have read it or
were forced to read it for a school
write this story about a couple of kids
who are in an in a crash of an airplane
and end up on an uninhabited island and
at the first day to think like oh this
is wonderful this is lovely and we're
gonna have a good time here and they try
to set up a democracy of sorts that it
quickly breaks down and at the end of
the novel like most of the kids have
become animals beasts savages and three
of the kids are dead and the message is
really here you have these civilized
nice kids from a good British boarding
schools but you give them freedom and
this is what what you get right
civilization is just a thin veneer now
for my book I realized that I had to do
something with our tooth flies right I
have to write something about it
even though it's it's fiction it's often
sort of used as nonfiction right so many
people interpret that novel and say oh
yeah that's that's what kids are like
India so I asked myself the question has
it ever happened you know has there ever
been one instance of real kids
ship-wrecking on a real island and what
would happen so yeah that's that's what
I I try to find out where do you start
when you think I wonder if there's been
a real world Lord of the flight because
you're you're a historian by training
and trades right and I always it as a
non historian
Robert Greene's been on this show Ryan
holidays just just arrived in my inbox
for later this year and I'm fascinated
by the process of finding history
because yeah it's not like it's
happening
yeah hyung go out and find some history
you've gotta like go back somehow well
you know there's this fantastic web site
that I can really recommend and that's
been very useful during my research and
it's called Google so that's basically
what everyone got excited there my eyes
widen to pieces I mean that's really
where I started as a proper
investigative journalist I basically
started googling so real Lord of the
Flies kids to shipwreck on an island and
I just try to find out whether it ever
happened and the first results you get
are all from like horrible reality
television shows right there was one in
the UK where they did this with children
iclear really horrible they tried to set
these kids up against each other etc etc
you don't want to know what kind of
bizarre and nasty ideas these television
makers have had in the past I still have
but then after a while I stumbled upon
some obscure blog with an anecdote about
yeah six kids that had supposedly
shipwrecked on an island in 1977 near
Tonga so as I got is this true so it has
this really happened song guys an island
group in the Pacific Ocean and yeah
that's basically when I started to try
and fact check this story whether it
really happened it's quite a difficult
process actually because I sort of kept
finding the same sort of paragraph short
paragraph about well had supposedly
happened in 1977 but I couldn't find any
article about it in the newspapers in
Australian newspapers for example and
you would really expect that if
something like that would really have
happened then there must be some article
somewhere right couldn't find it but
then I was just really lucky this is
also important if you want to have some
success in your research by accident I
had sort of types in the 1960s while I
was looking in a an archive of
Australian newspapers with pure
accidents I thought it was looking in
the 70s because supposedly it happened
in 1977 but I was looking in the 60s and
then I saw it
article from the Australian newspaper
the age that said that in 1966 six
Tomlin kids had shipwrecked on the
island of ahta which is a bit to the
south of Tonga and they have been
rescued by an Australian captain named
Peter Warner so that the ninety seventy
seven that was a typo it was in reality
was 1966 and then I realized I can maybe
find these people because if this really
happened in 1966 then they might still
be alive right there must be the the
kids themselves were 13 to 15 years old
at the time so they might still be alive
and to captain if I'm really really
lucky
he must be almost 90 now but maybe I can
find him as well so that's sort of how
that started and again I was really
lucky because it was about to promote my
new book sure to my previous book utopia
for realists and I was about to go on a
book tour in Australia so I said to my
publisher said you know what I need a
couple of days off because I think I've
got something interesting detour to make
there that's so cool man and so I saw
serendipitous as well that you just
happened to put the typo in that came up
with the story that you needed at the
time before you were about to fly there
isn't it cool how the world sort of
delivers stuff to us like yeah yeah yeah
I mean this is the kind of story that if
if it would be a fictional thing right
if it would be a novel or Hollywood
movie people would say oh that's so
unrealistic that is so sentimental that
is so naive
this is not how kids in real life would
really behave but you know as I started
researching this story more and more at
some point I was like I couldn't believe
it I thought people are not gonna
believe me if I report this to them
right so I gotta make sure that I
collect the evidence in the right way
because what did I find out is that
actually the real Lord of the Flies is a
story of hope and cooperation and
resilience and friendship these six kids
lift 450 months on an uninhabited island
basically five-0 five-0 fittingly 50
months yeah 15 sorry as always happens
as a Dutchman I can't that never it's
okay I will anglicize everything that
you say rector it's fine 51:5 year over
year which is still quite impressive
anyway they lived there for 15 months
and they did end up in fights every now
and then right that happens but then one
will go to one side of the island and
the other will go to the other side of
the island they would say the cool off a
little and say sorry and and cooperate
again so yeah that was really
fascinating and look at the guy who
rescued them Peter Warner it was also
sort of a larger than life kind of
person in the sense that turns out he's
the son of Arthur Warner who was sort of
the biggest media rich person in the
1930s he owned like the whole radio
industry and when Peter was 17 he ran
away from home because he in his words
he didn't want to fight people but he
wanted to fight nature so like for five
years he was lost to his family then he
came back and he said okay now I'm gonna
fish near Tonga and that's how by pure
accident he found these these six kids
and yeah they're still friends up until
this day so I mean the story gets even
crazier but I published his story in in
The Guardian a short part of it went
completely viral and suddenly all of
Hollywood wanted you know to have the
rights to this story so last week I had
a zoom call with the four survivor sixes
there were six of them initially but the
NAD they're still four still alive and
also with Peter Warner the captain who's
also still alive and so we had a zoom
called to decide together which big
Hollywood studio was going to get the
rights to this story and so way yeah
we've only just sold the rights it was a
very strange experience I was suddenly
talking old to all these top Hollywood
directors right who all wanted this
story but I felt you know I got a discus
this with with the others and yeah now
it's gonna go to the big screen
bro that's amazing that's crazy isn't it
III can't it still feels a little bit
surreal I mean the Internet
on the regular story one yeah it's I
don't think I'll ever get that lucky
again but it's really I mean it's a real
it's a story that really deserves
right I'm not saying it's a scientific
experiment or anything like that the
only thing I'm saying is that if
millions of kids around the globe still
have to read the fictional Lord of the
Flies which is fine I mean I think I
still like the novel and I sort of think
that you know it's it's good to think
about it and you can interpret it in
many different ways but then let's also
tell them about that one time that we
know of that real kid ship backs on a
real Island and they had three rules and
the first rule was have fun
yeah and that was in the fictional Lord
of the Flies yeah
and they actually did it he did it you
know they actually did the fun they
actually enjoyed that time there yeah
well I mean there were hard times as
well right especially during the summer
there was a real drought so they were
very thirsty they're very smart in
collecting rainwater as well
and at some point actually one of the
six broke a leg but they managed to heal
that Lac with traditional Toma medicine
yes it's really crazy yeah well I mean I
can't wait for the movie I'm sure that
everyone that's listening can't either
so um okay the idea underpinning
humankind your new book is we're not
quite as nasty as we might think yeah
that's the central idea and and it's uh
it may sound as a quite innocent idea
like oh this guy is written a book about
you when kindness isn't that nice but if
you really think it through it's a quite
radical idea a quite revolutionary idea
because throughout history a cynical
view of human nature has often been used
by those in power to legitimize their
power right because if we cannot trust
each other that we need managers and
CEOs and kings and monarchs and generals
right then we need to be kept in control
but if we can actually trust each other
if most people are pretty decent that
means that we maybe don't need them and
that we can move to a very different
kind of society that is much more
egalitarian genuinely democratic with
very different kind of organizations
different kind of schools different kind
of prisons democracies etc etc so it has
quiet yeah
big implications if you really think it
through so the rules and the bureaucracy
and the laws are there to protect us
from our own primitive nature and to
stop us just slinging feces at each
other in the street and and fighting by
O'Dea and pillaging by night is that
kind of do you think the the unspoken
reason for the current setup that we
have yeah I think that's sort of the all
legitimization of the way we've
organized the things you know this is
British philosopher Thomas Hobbes that's
probably one of the most influential
political philosophers we've ever had
and in the 70 century he wrote that in
the state of nature when people were
still nomadic hunter-gatherers which we
do inferring 95% of our history and we
had this war of all against all going on
and our lives were in his words nasty
brutish and short and then he made the
argument that in order to overcome this
we sort of appointed what he called a
Leviathan sort of a an all-powerful
ruler so that we gave away a freedom but
we got security back right and yeah that
was basically his argument now there was
another guy a bit later
the Frenchman jean-jacques Rousseau who
basically made the opposite argument he
said no no no no matic into galleries
they were awesome
you know they lived these fantastic
lives egalitarian healthy 2030 hour
workweek pretty relaxed
no war is peaceful you know pretty good
but then they came up with civilization
they settled down they became sedentary
and they started to become farmers and
live in cities and villages etc and it
was a total disaster right so they got
infection diseases they got wars they
got hierarchy they got paid tricky they
got and that was basically Russo's
arguments that civilization is the
disease that is actually the problem we
should go or at least try to go back to
the state of nature if at all possible
now usually a Hopf system has been
described as too realist as the smart
rational guy and Rousseau has been
described as the
revolutionary as the romantic idealist
but what really struck me while I was
researching this book is that if you go
deep into the latest evidence we have
from anthropology and archeology you
sort of get the feeling that actually on
most points Rousseau was right and hops
was wrong
so that indeed civilization can be
described the biggest part actually of
what we call civilization you know over
the last ten thousand years in many ways
it was actually epochs disaster for most
people tell us about the evolutionary
basis then you've discovered that
supports Rousseau's findings yeah so one
of the most interesting new theories
from evolutionary biology it is called
the self domestication theory so we all
know I think what domestication is right
you've got pigs
you've got cows and goats and whatever
right that have all been domesticated
which means that compared to their wild
ancestors they've become tamer right
more friendly and they can sort of work
with people or be enslaved by people
that's practically what it means now
what's interesting is that all these
domesticated species have a list of
specific traits so for example they've
got thinner bones smaller brains and
most importantly they just look a bit
more childish right we even know sort of
which genes are associated with the
domestication syndrome as they call it
and now it gets really interested
interesting if you look at us if you
look at human beings and if you compare
us to our ancestors like other hominid
species you live fifty thousand years
ago we look really domesticated so we
have thinner bones we have smaller
brains and we look childish compared to
our ancestors compared to Neanderthals
were sort of I like to call it home bug
puppy we're sort of puppyish and then
the question becomes only bigger right
how did we ever manage to conquer the
globe well the Neanderthals are gone if
we're this domesticated infantile I
think you mentioned in the book as well
that you actually have more feminine
traits that go across the board as well
is that right yeah yeah don't tell this
to all the durham peterson fans but what
evolutionary biology now has proven
basically is that over the past
thousands of years men have become more
feminine right so men have started to
look more like women and this is but I
guess sorry that's comparative to how we
either did look or would have looked had
that not have happened yes the men are
looking at men now and going I look like
a man that looks like a woman but the
the difference used to be bigger so and
you can look at other primates if you
look for example at chimpanzees or
gorillas gorillas at this I think a good
example you see this is really striking
differences between men and women but
actually they're those differences have
become smaller in human evolution now
there's a another term for this in
biology and they biologists call it
survival of the friendliest which means
that for a thousands of years it was
actually the friendliest among us who
got the most kids
so imagine Donald Trump in prehistory
well he wouldn't have done very well
because people wouldn't have liked him
probably they didn't like narcissists or
people were a bit too arrogant and so he
would have quickly been expelled from
the group and he wouldn't have been able
to survival in his own because in the
our deep history in the Stone Age having
friends was much more important than
having possessions you know you needed
friends to survive and how do you get
friends well not by being a jerk right
you have to be a bit friendly that's
that's only logical so the theory from
biologists now is that what makes human
being special is not so much that we're
very smart I mean we're clearly not we
as I said we've got smaller brains
compared to our ancestor so individual
level we're not very smart and if you do
an intelligence test and let a human
toddler compete with a pig then often
the pig wins we people should keep that
in mind when they eat bacon but it's
it's another you know a piece of
evidence that we're not not that smart
we're also not very strong I mean I know
some people are and they they put a lot
of effort in that at the gym but on
average you know
parasu of gorillas or a chimpanzee you
know you really don't want to do a
boxing match with with one of those I
think yeah you're will regret that so
the true superpower of human beings is
it's not you don't see it on an
individual level but on a group level
we're just really good at learning from
each other at cooperating from each
other with each other and that is what
scientists now believe is that is the
reason why we conquered the globe and we
managed to come up with all these
inventions and built pyramids and built
spaceships etc etc very different theory
than sort of the more cynical ideas we
had about our evolution a couple of
decades ago our adaptability to
different climates our ability to use
tools and things like that is that does
that map onto this somehow is that
enhanced by the cooperation or because
you know it Pig versus an infant makes
sense but a pig versus an adult human
study a little bit different and you
don't need to be perhaps as strong as a
gorilla if the tasks you're doing don't
require that level of strength they just
required the minimum viable level of
strength in order to complete those
tasks yeah rather than being a freak
Savage in the strength department or in
the speed department or in the endurance
Department by having a broad
cross-section I can or the all-rounder
player on your team you can actually be
quite still a very very effective and
overly competitive up against those but
yeah is that is is that something that
maps onto that with regards to our
skills and and of how we work together
well I've got a really great example
from the anthropologist Joseph Henrich
so he sort of asked us to imagine a
planet where there are two sort of
hominid species and the one are called
the geniuses they're really smart on an
individual level but they're not very
social right they don't have many
friends and the others are called the
copycat they're not very smart effect
they're a bit dumb but they just can't
stop talking and they talk about
everything you know with everyone and
they have a lot of friends now imagine
that they want to come up with a new
info
say like fishing or something like that
they want to learn how to fish
now obviously the geniuses have a much
bigger chance of coming up with it
invention right but they only share it
with a couple of others right so that's
that's the problem there because they're
they're very smart but they're not gonna
they only have like two or three friends
now if you have a copycat species where
most people are really stupid but one of
them comes up with something brilliant
you can be sure that very quickly
everyone knows how to fish and that's
that's how you should look at a human
evolution and what makes it so special
it's not that one on an individual level
so special but we just can't resist
sharing everything we know with everyone
all the time that's what happens that's
cool that's a cool I like that example
so there is some evolutionary basis for
the fact that we are cooperative rather
than adversarial that we are good rather
than bad then we see civilization and we
start to have all of these examples so
first of what what about when we go to
war we see people warring we have these
terrible crimes we have things like that
the Holocaust and truly evil people how
does that map yeah
the big question obviously that hangs
over a book like this how can we ever
explain all the great atrocities of of
our history because we're clearly not
only the friendliest species were also
the cruelest species in the animal
kingdom we do things that other animals
just they wouldn't have the nerve they
wouldn't have the imagination to be so
horrible right like ethnic cleansing and
genocides in the Holocaust and you name
it it's like singularly human to do
these kind of things so the interesting
thing here is that if you again look at
the sort of the whole curve of our
history what you see is that for
thousands of years people hardly waged
any wise so didn't really happen there
are archaeological evidence for example
for war before we became sedentary is
very thin anthropologists have studied
nomadic into gatherers and I found that
they're actually quite peaceful you know
but then we settle down and we started
living in villages and cities and groups
started forming and you starts to get
this in-group out-group behavior and
this is really where the history of
warfare begins
this is exactly what you find in the
archaeological record a really cool
piece of evidence here is cave paintings
so if there is really a war of all
against all going on in the Stone Age
then you would expect that at some point
some Picasso of the Stone Age would have
said you know what I'm gonna make my
granny cat you know of the serf of this
war I get all against all but we haven't
found it it's just not there but then
after we became sedentary you you see a
lot of Guernica right you see a lot of
evidence for warfare in these paintings
the question is obviously why did it
happened it's it's still I mean still
being discussed a lot this is one of the
great questions obviously about about
our history I think what important
dynamic is that when people said at that
settled down sort of collecting friends
became less important and collecting
possessions became more important or
collecting status people could also at
some point start to inherit those
possession and so then there could arise
status differences we know that nomadic
hunter-gatherers are very egalitarian
they have leaders but the cultural code
is really to be humble right you have to
be humble all the time for example if
you if you've been hunting and you come
back and you let's imagine you're a
really good hunter and you come back
with like an awesome deer or something
like that and then then you come back to
the camp and what you do is you say
nothing right you just put the deer
somewhere you're just gonna gonna sit
and it's like and then someone comes up
to you and say did you catch anything
today and you're like no not really no
it was a bad day and then that person
would know you know today is we're gonna
eat very well tonight
so humbleness was really sort of
prerequisite but then everything started
to change from we went from survival of
the friendliest to survive of the
shameless which I still think I mean you
can see that operating silt today in
politics right if you if you ask the
question how can people like Boston
arrow and Brazil or Boris Johnson or
Cummings right how could these people
have they no shame right why are they
still there
and and it turns out that now we have
created a society where shamelessness
can actually be an advantage it's really
interesting that human beings have we
have the most expressive faces in the in
the animal kingdom so we're one of the
very few that have the ability to blush
which I thought it was that amazing
right that were that we have this sort
of evolutionary advantage that we can
give away our feelings in volunteering
to other people now why do we do this
because it helps to establish trust also
if you look at our eyes is also really
special actually our eyes have white
around the irises which means that we
can follow each other gazes and all the
other primates don't have that there are
more than 200 primate species in total
and all of them have dark around their
eyes here right they're like mafia
players mafia members wearing shades
right or poker players wearing wearing
sunglasses for us we serve again we
involuntarily give away our gazes which
helps to establish trust between us now
where I'm going with this think about
those who are in powerful positions they
don't blush anymore right it's almost as
if they've become disconnected from
society and you can also see this in
brain scans for example put powerful
people in a brain scan and you'll see
that the regions that are involved with
empathy they don't really work that well
anymore so this is this is one of the
important mechanisms I think if you want
to explain you know the more horrible
and dark pages of human history it is
that power corrupts that's it's sort of
if I want to summarize my book in in one
sense sentence it would be something
like most people are pretty decent but
power corrupts
I get it I think
something that I would consider to do
with people in positions of power
especially those that are in the public
eye
which every person in a position of
power is now given that we can't always
on communication I would say that a
politician who overly showed their
emotions if Donald Trump was talking
about how challenging these times were
going to be over the the pandemic
lockdown and you had a single tear
rolling down his face I don't think that
that would be an effective strategy even
if that is truly what he felt and so I
do think that there has to be a level of
game playing where they have to dampen
down some of those emotions you know
yeah um if Donald Trump gets a
argumentative question and he's already
been fairly vitriol back like if he
takes it to the degree that his inner
most logos says they usually do you know
that might push a little bit hard but
man it's a it's a compelling case so far
let's move on to you you looked at some
fascinating stuff to do with war the way
the soldiers behave and stuff to do with
that talk to us about that
can I say one thing though about about
yeah sort of the point you just made
because that's really really interesting
France - Wow you know he's my fellow
Dutch man he's a primatologist and he's
been studying chimpanzees and bonobos
now for decades and in the 80s I believe
he wrote a book called chimpanzee
politics in which he described sort of
all the politics of zoo in the
Netherlands and he compared it to US
Congress and he made a very compelling
case that you know you see we see more
or less the same dynamic actually Newt
Green Green Green [ __ ] how to pronounce
that anyway you know who I mean the
American politician he saw he gave like
a lot of copies to his colleagues in
Congress because he was like yeah yeah
this is this is what we do you know
there's a book that says the playbook
there that's what we're doing next and
and there's quite some evidence that
indeed sort of them the standard sort of
patriarchal leaders behave a little bit
like a chimpanzee or that we often trust
leaders who have deeper voices or are a
longer etc that we tend to think they're
better leaders or something like that
I think this is inevitable though I
think there's also a real officer might
say for a different model of leadership
if you look at the extraordinary
popularity right now of someone like
Jacinda Arden in New Zealand right it
was clearly she's like the nomadic and
together a kind of leader she she took
she constantly makes self-depreciating
jokes right she makes fun of herself she
sort of has this more egalitarian
leadership model I think which also has
its risk right because as I said power
corrupts so it's often hard to keep it
going like that you need to have this
egalitarian culture what's interesting
by the way I also think that there's a
big difference between American culture
and in Dutch culture you know where I'm
from is because American culture if
you're successful then it's like ooh
cool Wow have you become successful you
must be great in the Netherlands if
you're successful we consider that a
crime right that's not you have to
apologize for being successful sorry you
must be apologizing I totally forgot
you're number two on the Sunday Times
bestseller list yeah yeah that's
congratulations and at the same time
you're a terrible sovereign you should
be very sorry actually I mean really I
mean it may sound a bit ridiculous but
it's actually really healthy because
yeah as I said you know power corrupts
so there needs to be some kind of
control mechanisms and this is one of
them now to get back to your question
how people behave during wars because
again this is this is a question that I
have to come back again and again in my
book how can people do all these kind of
horrible things right if we've really
evolved to be friendly then why can be
so can we be so violent now the
interesting thing here is that we
obviously like things like sex right you
don't have to explain that to anyone why
sex is fun or nice at least most with
most of us like it and food is the same
thing right our body immediately rewards
us for eating something when we're
hungry you know it just feels good now
what's interesting with violence is that
it's actually different we know from a
huge amount of evidence that soldiers
who've killed in wars often come back
with PTSD you
traumatized which is strange you know if
it would really be our evolutionary
destiny to be killing other people then
why doesn't our nature reward us for
killing other people it's that that's
not what happens in reality silence is
really really difficult for most of us
especially when people are are very
close so if you have to show a bayonet
or sort down someone most of us just
can't do it if you look at the evidence
that we have from big battles like the
Battle of Waterloo or the Battle of the
Somme during the First World War
almost none of the wounds were caused by
bayonets you know there's one historian
who writes that that as soon as two
armies approach each other and they come
become too close and it becomes clear
that they have to fight with these
bayonets then most of the time one of
them remembers an urgent appointment
somewhere else and just goes away right
because they just can't do it
Wow now it becomes already easier if you
can actually shoot at the enemy right so
if you have some distance this is a
really important innovation in warfare
but then still most people can't do it
and we know from evidence from the
Second World War there's been this
historian American historian who went
with the troops in Europe and the
Pacific
and interviewed them afterwards his name
was SLA marshal he read a book about
this men against fire and he discovered
that the majority of the soldiers didn't
shoot they couldn't do it they or they
they sort of shot over over the enemy
and they didn't actually aim for them
his estimate was that only 15 to 25
percent of soldiers actually shot
there's been quite some controversy
around that figure it seems as it was
sort of more intuitive guess instead of
like heart statistics but we now have a
lot of other evidence from you know
modern sociologists who back up this
finding so most experts now also believe
that actually like the regularly
standard drafted soldier you know just
twice it's really hard to be violent and
this finding was taken very seriously by
the US military because after the Second
World War they were like very worried
like our soldiers are not doing their
job right they have to shoot at the
enemy and they're not doing
so what they did is they started this
whole program of brainwashing and
conditioning their soldiers so that sort
of shooting becomes a standard reaction
sort of a Pavlov reaction you do it
immediately once you see a target that
looks a little bit like a human being
and so then the firing rate went up in
the Korean War and also in the Vietnam
War but obviously because more soldiers
started killing other people they there
were also many more cases of PTSD and
many of them came back and they had not
only killed someone else but also killed
something inside themselves now
obviously the most simple reason to
overcome this is to use tools like
artillery if you just push a button and
have an explosion far away that's doable
or just drop an atomic bomb on a city
the the the person who did this on I
think Hiroshima or Nagasaki was once
interviewed and asked you know do you
have any more remorse for killing tens
of thousands of people you know by
pushing that button you said now don't
feel that he got the guy in the plane
yeah exactly but imagine having to
slaughter fifty thousand people with a
knife fine and yes exactly most people
could just the same with I mean most
people would be come vegetarian very
quickly if they would have to kill their
own cow before they could have a steak
right most people couldn't do it but
we've enabled this huge meat industry
where billions of animals are killed
every year I don't know it's like sixty
billion animals every year and on the
planet and we've able to do been able to
do that by increasing the distance right
we don't see it anymore it's become
weird yeah it's it's not it's not real
anymore in that way and this is really
the history of military technology
increasing the distance increasing the
distance so that's sort of likely the
physical distance but you can also
increase the psychological distance and
that's a very important part in ethnic
cleansing and genocide is what happens
is that human beings have the ability to
dehumanize others right until look at
them and not see people but see things
this is a process that takes quite a lot
of time right
it needs a lot of propaganda and a lot
of horrible and nasty stuff but we've
seen it happening quite a few times in
history and then also things are
possible that are just yeah really
really horrible and are really the dark
side of our of our nature
it's interesting how all of these
advances all of these tactics are
shortcutting a compassion set point or
an empathy set point I suppose is you
know II think the people that are
listening
imagine the Conscription happened in
whatever country you're in tomorrow and
you got called up you could have all the
training in the world I know how to
clean the rifle I know how I run and I'm
gonna pack my bag I can dig a foxhole I
can send up a flare I can do all this
sort of stuff yeah at no point during
that does it get around the fact like I
don't want to kill someone I don't know
no desire to kill someone yeah and just
because they're on what is essentially
like the other team like where red team
and their blue team that's kind of what
it is yeah there is a it doesn't
surprise me although it's shocking it's
also not surprising it's illogical in a
way and I think this is having read
human kind this is kind of my key
insight regarding my own life and I
think a lot of people that are listening
will have this as well which is that my
own experience of the world is that of
someone who is mostly kind like a [ __ ]
up sometimes like we all do and I do
reprehensible stuff that I'm embarrassed
about and blah blah blah
but for the most part you know they're
not big transgressions I have no desire
to do most of the nasty things that hit
the news and yet I believed that the
vast majority of people out there we
need to be kept safe from bad news and
there's this just huge undercurrent
underclass of people whatever it is
they're just ready to rise up and
pillage and rape and do all this yeah
despite having never seen that nature
within myself so there was just a part
of me that presumed well yeah that
that's you that's you're in speery ins
push the people around me like moment
dad and my friends and but I was I just
kind of taken it for granted I've been
delivered this grand narrative from
somewhere that it may become a part of
me and then started to like emerge out
of me where I thought well yeah no but
like look at look at all of the evidence
you know look at all of this stuff it
goes on and I think that that's been the
biggest insight that I took away from
this was that the description of the
type of nature of a person written in
human kind is significantly closer to my
experience of the world mm-hmm that make
sense yeah I mean that that way the
message of the book is very simple other
people are just like you just like you
yeah I mean you're probably not a
monster so they're probably not a
monster either right it's the weird
thing is that it's it's relatively easy
to assume the best in those who are
close to you you know as you said your
friends your neighbors your colleagues
but then as the distance increases again
we start to have these very weird
assumptions about other people so my
previous book was about the idea of
giving everyone a universal basic income
all right completely eradicating poverty
giving everyone some venture capital to
start a new company move to a different
job right and that idea is all about
trust it's about trusting other people
the most important objection people have
against it is oh those other people
they'll waste it right they'll they'll
buy drugs and alcohol they'll they'll
stop working etc
and then I would also always ask them
but what would you do with the basic
income and they will come up with all
these wonderful ideas and dreams are
like god this is interesting and then I
was them but other people do
Oh other people yeah oh but then we got
there isn't it yeah yeah distrust of the
other yeah yeah and I think it's
important that we yeah start moving to a
more realistic view of human nature it's
hard it's hard because it's the cynicism
is deeply deeply embedded in our culture
and we live in a
world where we have this whole
information system called the news that
on a daily basis bombard sirs with
horrible stuff about other people write
about corruption about crime of violence
so if you watch all of the news at the
end of the day you know exactly how the
world doesn't work because you've only
been hearing about all these exceptions
and you'll have a very cynical and bleak
view of humanity so you got to stop
there you know stop following the news
but then you go deeper and you've got
this whole Western culture you know we
talked about this goes back all the way
to the ancient Greeks who have this
cynical view of human nature and then
it's also in the interest of those in
power for us to be cynical because then
we legitimate their position because
then they'll say yeah and that's where
you meet us and then at the deepest
level we've got the problem of our own
negativity bias right and this is the
psychological term negativity bias human
beings just focused more on the negative
then on the positive it's the fact about
us
evil for us is stronger than good
there's probably some evolutionary
reason for that it's probably you know
if you were an American together it was
probably smart to be afraid once too
often instead of not afraid enough for a
spider or a snake or something like that
but now in this world where as I said
we're being bombarded we'll all kind of
horrible stories this negativity bias is
really holding us back
and I mean it's the same with your
probably experienced if experience it if
you get like ten compliments for your
podcast that's like that's nice but then
you get one piece of criticism right and
that's what what he wipes it out yeah
it's just more powerful I can't remember
who it was who's Alex O'Connor car
behind cosmic skeptic podcaster I'm
gonna put you in touch with once we
finish actually cuz you'd love him he
gave me this example for neonatal ISM he
gave me this this justification for it
which was the a hundred units of
suffering are so much worse than a
hundred units of pleasure and when you
then take that to a tenth degree in a
total utilitarian approach then you can
end up with these kind of quite weird
world views but you've hit the nail on
the head there that we would much sooner
not be in pain
than expirience a bit of pleasure pain
is so much more disproportionately buts
okay so I you know I think that's a
a strange and well depending but
realistic and easy enough to understand
from a personal experience perspective
view of human nature but if that's the
case like let's say that we are kind
what what's the implications for this
okay so what I think we gotta start
doing is to implement this theory of
human nature in our society because what
you assume is what you get if you assume
that most people are selfish
then you'll design all your schools and
your democracies and your workplaces
around that idea and I think you'll
bring out the worst in other people so
imagine that happen yeah well I imagine
you have sort of a workplace I think the
financial sector is a good of an example
of that sort of the City of London and
that's like this war of all against all
right and most relations there are nasty
brutish and short it's very competitive
and everyone expects that from everyone
so that's sort of what you get out of
people now if you turn it around and in
my book I give it a couple of examples
that do that of organisations that do
that you can have a very different kind
of organization so one example is an
organization called Bert's or in the
Netherlands which translates as
neighborhood care now what they did they
started in 2006 with a seemingly crazy
idea they ditched all the managers they
work only in self-directed teams of
twelve to thirteen IRS's and they only
deliver one product which is called care
that's what they do they deliver care
and now at first this was almost illegal
in the healthcare system of the
Netherlands at the time because they
just introduced so-called market forces
and everything had to become more
competitive and cheaper etc and the idea
was then that that would improve
healthcare but it really didn't so this
company started and initially insurance
insurance didn't want to finance it
etcetera but they went ahead anyway and
now it's one of the biggest
organizations in the Netherlands in
health care with 15,000 employees and
the really interesting thing is that
they deliver a health care now according
to independent observers at a cheaper
cost and of higher quality for for
clients and that they also pay higher
salaries to to their employees so it's
like
win-win-win and how they do do this well
it's all about trusting people to to do
their job on their own right because
nurses can really have this powerful
intrinsic motivation right they don't do
this kind of work because they want to
become rich or or you know are looking
for the status or anything but they
really want to help other people so if
you trust them to do that and if you say
okay your work in a team where you can
decide for yourself who you want to hire
what kind of additional education you
need what times you're gonna work this
week and next week etc it's actually
incredibly powerful and empowering and
that is sort of an example of the
direction we can move in if we actually
start trusting other people that I'm
gonna guess is enabled by the small
groups if you push into a particularly
large business you're not going to be
able to coordinate activities
sufficiently well you're gonna have
scheduling conflicts and all this sort
of stuff so the Malthusian trap this
kind of race to the bottom and the the
diluting down of all of this sort of
stuff how would you it sounds great you
know it's out it intellectually it makes
sense but there will be a lot of people
listening that like well yeah that's
that's all well and nice in this ideal
utopia which doesn't which doesn't exist
and the people that try and do the good
version of humanity are just going to
get out competed by the people that are
prepared to play the game more
effectively and sacrifice virtue for
value hmm-hmm well the examples that I'm
talking about are not small as I said
the company had just talked about 15,000
employees if you look at other models
for example the idea of having a
participatory democracy where citizens
are not just these people who sit on a
couch watch television and vote every
three or four years or something like
that and and become really angry but you
can actually also have a model where
average citizens are involved and are
randomly selected to become a politician
themselves every now and then
and this doesn't get a lot of attention
in the press but we've had huge
experiments in Latin America for example
there's a city called porto alegre where
they've been doing this ever since the
1980s on a very very big skill with tens
of thousands of people involved i think
it is entirely possible but yeah you
need to change a lot of your assumptions
there before it before you can make it
work i think the problem is not so much
skill but it's more hierarchy that's
that's really the problem because if you
have those at the top now what they want
to do is they they want to be in control
and what do you need if you want to be
in control well you need to start
measuring things right you want to have
in education for example you want to
have standardized tests so that you can
know how the kids are doing if they're
learning anything why are you using a
very narrow definition of learning
obviously because i mean there's so many
things that you can't measure right if
someone is becoming more creative howhow
are you ever gonna measure that so
obviously if you have a hierarchical
school system with standardized tests
then you know you're not gonna educate
your kids to be creative i mean this is
all the kind of effects that you that
you have if you have a traditional way
of thinking if you move to a different
kind of thinking and i think you can
rely more on what psychologists call
intrinsic motivation right so this is
they always make this distinction
between intrinsic motivation and
extrinsic motivation extrinsic is you do
something because you have to be or
because you want the money or you want
the the status or the prestige or you do
before your LinkedIn profile or because
your boss says you got to do it and
interesting motivation is because you
because you want it right because you
you're just curious because you just
creative you you you want to learn
something and one of the most important
findings of psychology in the past
couple of decades has been that these
two forms of motivation are both
powerful but they don't add up all right
they actually detract from each other
you can't if you rely more on extrinsic
motivation right more on on hierarchy
and on money and those kind of things
then people lose their intrinsic
motivation at some point they don't
really know why they're doing what
they're doing anymore now if you focus
or an intrinsic motivation then people
sort of lose interest in the other thing
and I think that's actually the the
direction we should be going as a
society because one of the great
tragedies of our time is that there are
so many people stuck in jobs that they
hate right so many smart people wasting
their talent I always sometimes give
this happens very rarely but I sometimes
give talks to bankers and I always say
to bankers look guys you're way too
smart to be a banker right it's just a
big tragedy that you're doing this
you're creating these destructive
financial products that don't have
anything to society and you know it and
you could be thinking about the cure for
cancer
you could be you know helping us get to
Mars or or whatever right build a flying
car and look what you're doing it's such
a tragedy
was it um an interview that I heard with
you where you said it's a tragedy that
some of the greatest minds of our time
have been spent working out how to get
people to click on ads yeah yeah yeah
that's that's actually a former Facebook
employee who says that
yeah you're in the you're in the pitch
black now it's just wandering over there
I'm just gonna keep on talking this can
be a monologue podcast now is that
better ah looks lovely man
full full beam but yeah that uh that
thing there's a lot of my buddies
working PPC cost-per-click Facebook Ads
funnels retargeting marketing stuff like
that yeah yeah I'm saying I'm not saying
that it's all useless I'm just saying
that we should listen to those people
who talk about their own jobs and say
you know what my job is not very
valuable writing reports that no one's
ever going to read I am coming up with
these stupid products and it's it's it's
just sad it's really sad it's I mean
it's it's also I think a reason why we
need to rethink sort of the value of the
public sector versus the private sector
so what has happened two years ago is
that a really big and important study
came out from two Dutch economists who
who looks at a huge poll that have been
done a mom like 30,000 people in 40
countries and they discovered that
around 25 percent of the modern
workforce things his or her own job is
socially meaningless doesn't have
anything of value to society they also
discovered that these jobs are often you
know they have high salaries so you have
people with beautiful LinkedIn profiles
good salaries but still at the end of
the day they think their job is useless
and most interestingly there are four
times as many socially meaningless jobs
in the private sector as in the public
sector which is sort of counterintuitive
right people often think that oh the
government is so wasteful and they come
up with all these jobs that don't need
to exist come on only entrepreneurs
create real jobs but if we think about
for a bit longer it starts to make sense
because a lot of jobs in education and
health care they're government jobs
right and they're clearly useful if you
look at all these lists from the so
called vital professions right
they've been published during the
pandemic so many governments have gone
that with the vital and essential
workers many of them are actually public
jobs now if you then look at the jobs
that maybe don't as much a value it's
like people working in finance or
marketing or consultancy or whatever and
and remember it's not me saying it's
people themselves saying it about their
own job pockets don't care about
people's feelings right you don't worry
about that
okay okay no but I mean people can
listen to this like this guy's a
historian that's like the definition of
[ __ ] so it's important that people
can decide that for themselves I think
that this term by the way [ __ ] job
is an academic term coined by the
anthropologist David Craver so it's a
real academic thing right now that's the
official official term
I mean I could I mean the the recent
relevant elephant in the room
mm-hmm is the pandemic it is the fact
that we have gone through biggest thing
to happen for a generation probably for
newly you know 60 years or whatever sort
of two seven eight years back until
World War two and one of the reasons
that there was a
slow onset of lockdown in the UK was
because of fears of backlash from the
the proletariat in the street just
ripping [ __ ] off the walls and we
haven't we you know and in homage to
these hypothesis that you are putting
forward here we haven't seen the rioting
we haven't seen the misbehavior
we just before we started it's just as
well that we did start five minutes late
bingos it was the eight pm get your pots
and pans out and smash seven shades out
of them for the NHS thing that was going
here so you know we haven't we haven't
seen that and that is happening right
now right yeah this very second everyone
listening is experienced it yeah yeah I
mean it's just history repeating itself
I start the book with the example of
Great Britain at the eve of the Second
World War where and also the elites
including Churchill believed that people
wouldn't be able to handle the ball
being war you know and they were really
afraid that once the Germans would start
bombing London and other cities that
people would go nuts that they would
panic they would start looting they
would you know have mental breakdowns
and all that kind of stuff so there were
a lot of psychiatric field hospital set
up at the the last moment and all kinds
of emergency measures taking were taken
then the bombs did start falling in
September 1940 and and didn't happen you
know the world there was no mass panic
actually it was the opposite so did they
keep calm and carry on
meant to have at sea I really had a had
a good time sort of reading all these
anecdotes from back then and all the
lovely British jokes so what happened a
lot is that for example a restaurant was
bombed or a pub was bombed and then the
owner would put a sign outside that says
more open than usual right all right
like our spirits are ex excellent come
in and try them I mean that's kind of
jokes like yeah yeah it's um watching it
unfold you know I
it's the the that story at the beginning
as well as absolutely fascinating where
there was kind of this weird conspiracy
thing which had occurred which then
legitimized British bombing via Dresden
and other places and like in one night
in Dresden was that was the same tonnage
of bombs that was dropped across an
entire year and that was justified by
some army commander that basically
couldn't find anything to yeah back up
what he thought is it feels like there
is this huge conspiracy that's been
occurring since the beginning of human
history to make us believe that
inherently were quite adversarial and
mean yeah well I wouldn't I wouldn't
describe it as a conspiracy because
elites are not smart enough for
conspiracy in general yeah conspiracies
in general right they're not smart
enough to coordinate that kind of thing
but it is something that sort of how do
you say that organically happens again
and again because it's in the interest
of the leads to spread cynical stories
about who we are as a species so indeed
what happened again in the Second World
War is that Frederick Lindemann who was
a the best friend of Churchill he was
the guy who had to do research into the
effects of the bombing on Britain and
what the scientists found again and
again is that you know there was no
breakdown of morale at all actually
there was some evidence that the cities
were who were bombed really hard
actually had more resilience and that
their war production was going up but
then Lindemann didn't like the
conclusion and so he said to Churchill
you know what bombing is really
effective and if we just bombed Germans
Germany 10 times as heavily it's gonna
be awesome you know it's gonna we're
gonna break this you're gonna be oh yeah
it's gonna it's gonna be really
effective and so that's what they did
and they did drop ten times as many
bombs in Germany and then later after
the war British scientists went to
Germany to study effects of the bombing
and they found the exact same thing that
the cities who had suffered the most
also had increased wartime production
compared to the cities who were not
bombed as happy so there are even
historians now who believe that if there
had been no booming war or if the
airplanes have been used to bomb
strategic targets like railroads and
Industry and factories that the war you
know wouldn't would have been shorter
like six months shorter or something
like that it's pretty incredible
that's what story man so I want to
finish off you give ten rules to live by
at the end of the book do you have a do
you have a favorite oh this is a
question you know I should first say
that I didn't want to write a self-help
book you know I'm not I'm not really
into self-help maybe because I'm not
really good at it either but I really
believe that sort of a different world
starts with building different kind of
institutions people are shaped by
institutions by the schools we we go to
by the workplaces where we work right by
our prisons by the way our democracy is
organized is organized so I think it
really starts there we shouldn't expect
too much of individuals but then again I
couldn't resist I thought you know there
are probably some rules for life that I
can come up with if we take this view of
human nature seriously so the rule that
I start with is quite simple it's when
in doubt assume the best and very often
we do the opposite you know if you're
communicating with someone else and
especially when there are some distance
in the communication let's say you're on
whatsapp and you get all these emojis
and you're like what does that emoji
mean and you start interpreting and then
often we quickly have our doubts about
other people's intentions even though we
don't have solid evidence that they
really mean something in a nasty way we
quickly start to do this and then we
adjust our behavior we've become a
little bit less friendly and then the
other person also start saying you know
that's weird I know I'm getting all so
weird emojis right and this is how
relationships sometimes break down right
how people end up in fights because of
this kind of miscommunication and where
people are assuming the worst in each
other now I think we should turn it
around when in doubt always assume the
best why do you do need to do that in
the first place because most people are
pretty decent so most of the time you'll
be right it's just a good guess
in the second place because your
behavior can have non complimentary
effects this is psychological term so if
someone is like really being nasty and
you act in a nice way to that person
then you could sort of break the circle
right it's very hard to stay nasty to
someone who's like being nice who's
turning the other cheek it's I've got
one example in my book which is I mean
this is a very sentimental example but
I'm gonna tell it anyway this happened
like I don't know 10 20 years ago in New
York it was a guy who was being dropped
in the in the in the subway and by a by
a young guy with a knife and he said
like your money or your life and it's
okay here you have my money and the guy
was about to go away the robber was
about to go away and then the man who
you know who'd been attacked said wait a
minute don't you want my coat as well
you know it's quite cold and and then
the guy said you know what my favorite
restaurant is around the corner here so
we just go there together and just talk
about it so they went there and they had
a they had a lovely night and a good
discussion about life and then it was
the end of the night and did the bill
came for the food they had and so the
man who had just been robbed said you
know you've got my wallet so and and and
you know they became friends and it's
it's this very sentimental example of
just the power of non complementarity in
no complementarian right non
complimentary behavior now you can say
yeah but there are still nasty people
out there right there are still
professional con men who will just try
to rip you off there are sociopaths
there are psychopaths what about them
well
I came to realize that we should accept
some amount of collateral damage in our
lives right because if you really want
to never want to be ripped off never in
your life then you have to distrust
other people all the time you can only
trust those close to you and then you
have to distrust all those strangers
that price is way too high to pay so
what I think the rational thing to do is
to have a very trusting attitude to
other people in general and just accept
that you'll be ripped off a couple of
times in your life you know it's a
reasonable rational price to pay and so
if you are I don't know 30 40 years old
50 years old and you've still never been
ripped off you've never been conned
you should really ask yourself what's
wrong with me you know you shoot maybe
visit a therapist because your basic
attitudes to life is not trusting enough
right it should be something that year I
mean you can be proud of being ripped
off a couple of times and being called a
couple of times that's an interesting
way to look at it when I think it's a
little bit like putting a trade on or
being a trader and consistently making
small positive wins throughout your life
concealing the fact that your current
trading strategy will mean you have a
few fairly medium-sized losses here and
there but hopefully there won't be too
frequent hopefully there won't be too
catastrophic and you just keep on going
well I think um I think the main
challenge people are going to have in
swallowing the the ideas in humankind is
going to be getting past first their
societal programming but also as you
mentioned this sort of negativity
default that we have it's Fitness
enhancing there's a lot of anxiety at
the moment people are cautious about
opening up they don't want to feel silly
when they try and do something nice to
someone you know someone's like be mean
to you and you it's seen as a little bit
wimpy you turn the cheek so there's more
society coming in but when mimetic
creatures man you know like the more
nice that we can be the more nice those
around us can be and this is why
particularly I love this project I love
the podcasts that I have because it
connects me with people who think the
things that I think about the world
which is that they want to understand
themselves they want to understand the
world around them and that's awesome I'm
like look at rising tide and all ships
let's keep let's keep going you know
like tsunami time um man I uh I really I
really think the fact that it's number
two on the Sunday Times bestseller list
as well is something that you should be
incredibly proud of and embarrassed by
obviously at the same time dude I think
I'm super super happy for you I think
it's got a beautiful message so people
want to people want to check it out
check out the book find you online where
they go oh they can just google it I
guess secret website yes well humankind
hopeful history will be linked in the
show notes below on Amazon
Rutgers Twitter which is
disproportionately massive after going
viral like five times in the last year
you've got this huge this huge like
Twitter influencer sized following
online after completely smashing the
internet from the lot for the last
twelve months
at all if that will be linked in the
show notes below Rutger man it's been
it's been awesome thank you so much for
your time thank you somewhere to really
enjoy this
[Music]
you